this from David Powers police who said
they were called to a property just
before 10 o'clock last night near a
crimmage and where a four-year-old girl
died at the scene they have named uh the
girl who died there as Alicia Salisbury
and already Alicia's family have
described her as a beautiful daughter
and sister in the family you'll
understand beside themselves right now
they're being supported by a specialist
officers it's not clear if anyone else
was injured in the fire but we know that
this four-year-old girl who you can see
on your screens Alicia Salisbury died at
the scene of this place at a house in
crimmage David Powers police confirming
the fire at around 10 o'clock last night
and the liaison officer with police says
our thoughts are with the family and
local community at this tragic time the
coroner has been informed officers will
now work with colleagues from the fire
service us to establish the cause of
this fire as you might expect the police
officers saying the family requests
privacy at this difficult time so that
is uh four-year-old Alicia Salisbury
who's died in a fire in pembrokeshire at
a house near crimmage last night